Justin here with a gamespot news update
it looks like the playstation 4 might
have a price drop on the way soon North
American retailer target has updated its
video games hub to reveal what could be
a fifty dollar price drop for the
PlayStation 4 the image show live now on
the retailer site suggests that a fifty
dollar price drop is coming soon meaning
the system will start at 349 instead of
399 in the United States for now this is
unconfirmed target is also currently
running a limited time promotion where
it's giving away fifty dollar gift cards
with the purchase of select ps4 bundles
however the wording in this image
suggests it's referring to a permanent
price drop in addition the image used in
the price drop banner is for uncharted
beneath and Drake collection which is
not one of the titles that comes with a
gift card shortly after sony announced a
price drop for the console and japan
xbox head filled Spencer said that he
expects a price drop before the holidays
since the PlayStation 4 is launched in
2013 the consoles prices stay the same
while the Xbox one has undergone
multiple price drops over the last two
years we reached out to Sony for more
details in the meantime stay tuned to
gamespot for even more video game news
you